With the absurd amount of content flooding
our multiplex screens every year, it stands
to reason that more than a few films will
fail to score with the public.
As different as they may be, these movies
all suffered the same unfortunate fate.
Some were unnecessary, some struggled to market
themselves and some simply failed to deliver,
but every last one of them tanked at the box
office.
Here’s why.
Solo: A Star Wars Story
It seems preposterous to even entertain the
notion that a Star Wars movie could be anything
but a smash hit, but here we are.
Solo: A Star Wars Story opened in May to something
of a shrug from audiences.
It's not even that the movie was particularly
bad, it's just that Solo never seemed to be
a movie that Star Wars fans ever wanted.
Many fans felt that fleshing out the backstory
of one of the franchise's most beloved characters
was completely unnecessary.
And while Donald Glover shone as a young Lando
Calrissian and Alden Ehrenreich turned in
an admirable performance as Solo himself,
these characters were afflicted by a thin
story which added little to the saga as a
whole.
Releasing Solo five months after The Last
Jedi, and only a month after Avengers: Infinity
War, can’t have helped things, either.
Skyscraper
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson’s latest summer
blockbuster seemed almost genetically engineered
for success.
It was a fresh IP, hyped as this generation’s
Die Hard, and starred one of the most bankable
stars working in Hollywood today.
But while critics were split down the middle
when Skyscraper hit theaters, audiences found
themselves supremely uninterested by the movie’s
release.
With a $125 million budget and a gargantuan
advertising campaign to match, Skyscraper
would have had to do absolute gangbusters
at the box office to avoid losing money.
Despite a decent overseas reception, thanks
largely to the movie’s Hong Kong setting
and diverse cast, success just never materialized.
The movie’s derivative plot probably frustrated
audiences as much as it did critics, and,
with Skyscraper coming so soon after the release
of Jumanji and Rampage, you can’t discount
Rock fatigue as a factor in the movie’s
unfortunate demise.
A Wrinkle in Time
Disney’s adaptation of the beloved novel
by Madeleine L’Engle encouraged high expectations.
It had a stellar cast and an admirable commitment
to diversity, being the first big-budget,
tentpole movie to be directed by a black woman,
the exceedingly talented Ava DuVernay.
With Young Adult franchises like Harry Potter
and The Hunger Games dominating the box office
in recent years, A Wrinkle in Time could reasonably
have been expected to be a smash hit.
Sadly, this never happened.
The movie failed to encourage the kind of
diverse audiences Black Panther had gathered
a few weeks earlier and, perhaps due to its
lukewarm critical response, none of the usual
young adult movie crowds showed up, either.
The film's convoluted marketing campaign didn't
help, and Wrinkle ended up scraping together
just over $100 million in the United States.
“To you I give the gift of your faults…
you’re welcome.”
The Hurricane Heist
The involvement of Rob Cohen, best known for
directing the original Fast and the Furious
and xXx , lent a degree of anticipation to
The Hurricane Heist’s box office chances,
and the more optimistic dared to hope the
movie might have been one of those high-octane,
stunt-heavy action flicks which inevitably
bloom into profitable franchises.
Unfortunately, critics skewered the movie
at release for its rip-off narrative, plot
holes and poor editing.
Audiences took note.
In the end, The Hurricane Heist failed to
break $1 million on its first day and grossed
just over $6 million at the end of its theatrical
run, just one sixth of its production budget.
Annihilation
Based on the critically-acclaimed Jeff VanderMeer
novel of the same name, Annihilation is the
story of a team of scientists who venture
into the Shimmer, a place unconfined by the
laws of reality.
It’s also a very good movie, critics were
quick to sing its praises.
Despite this, however, audiences responded
to its release with near-total indifference.
“How is that possible?
You must be able to tell me something."
Paramount may have shot down Annihilation’s
box office chances by striking a deal for
the movie’s international streaming rights
prior to release.
It dropped on Netflix around the time of its
theatrical release in virtually every market
except North America and China, severely cutting
into its overseas profits.
In the States, it went up against Black Panther.
Unsurprisingly, Annihilation failed to break
even on its $40 million budget.